[Musik]
als ich am 19
aufstand spürte ich dass ich nicht mehr
atmete wie sonst es war als ob ich unter
wasser sah ich bekam keine luft
das war das schlimmste erlebnis meines
lebens
ich wurde intubiert und von da an weiß
ich nichts mehr
[Musik]
drei menschen die das virus überlebt
haben tagelang schwebte sie zwischen
leben und tod
jetzt sind sie auf dem weg zurück ins
leben die tessiner rehaklinik nova und
die klinik hebebrand in brissago helfen
ihnen dabei
[Musik]
ich bekam einfach keine luft mehr das
ist schwer zu beschreiben auch weil ich
mich an vieles nicht mehr erinnern
[Musik]
anfang märz fühlte sich der band serie
matt und fiebrig sicherheitshalber begab
sie sich selber in quarantäne
doch ihr zustand verschlechterte sich
schnell ein notarzt verschrieb ihr
medikamente veranlasste aber keinen
virus test dann überstürzten sich
plötzlich die ereignisse
ich weiß nur noch dass sich in die
intensivstation des spitals gebracht und
dort zitiert und integriert wurde
aber ich erinnere mich an nichts
das alles haben sie mir später erzählt
[Musik]
bei roberto gatti begann es am freitag
dem 13
märz starkes unwohlsein fieber extremes
kopfweh sein hausarzt überwies ihn ins
regionalspital mendrisio der virus test
machte alles klar
corona positiv nur einmal habe ich
darüber nachgedacht was alles passieren
könnte
das war als sie mich mit dem
krankenwagen ins spital fuhren
er schoss es mir durch den kopf dass ich
meine familie vielleicht nie wieder
sehen würde dass das ein abschied für
immer sein könnte ohne weitere kontakte
mein ganzes leben lief wie ein film vor
meinen augen ab
und dann plötzlich ein blitz elena
merlini ist 39 und leidet an einer
autoimmunkrankheit der hmi asthenie
welche zu einer extrem staaten ermüdung
der muskeln führt die infektion mit dem
corona virus wirkte sich verheerend aus
als sie im caritas spital locarno ankam
war ihr zustand bereits kritisch ich war
schon drei tage dort als sich die tür
öffnete und vier anästhesisten
hereinkamen und ein arzt mit einer
maschine
sie eröffneten mehr dass sie mich
intubieren müssten weil sie das
schlimmste verhindern wollten
ich hatte keine zeit mehr meinen partner
anzurufen
ich telefonierte nur noch mit meiner
mutter und sagte mama sie müssten mich
intubieren und gab das telefon dem arzt
weiter ich weiß noch dass sich die ärzte
anflehte sie sollten mich nicht sterben
lassen
ich habe sie wirklich angefleht
[Musik]
hatten sie angst in meinem ganzen leben
hatte ich noch nie solche angst ich
wachte auf
ich fühlte mich miserabel die zunge war
wir aus karton die kehle völlig
ausgetrocknet und durst hatte ich der
durst hat mich die ganze zeit begleitet
sogar jetzt noch aber sonst weiß ich
nichts mehr
meine familie hat höllenqualen gelitten
als ich wieder zu mir kam hatte ich sie
immer wieder um entschuldigung für das
innere leere verwirrung angst vor dem
kontrollverlust daran leiden die
patienten die 15 oder gar 15 tage
hinterwirth waren noch heute ein loch in
der erinnerung
[Musik]
an sich dieser patienten das erste mal
sah als sie eingeliefert wurden
sie blickten ins leere als ob sie einen
fixpunkt suchten also bienen noch nicht
bewusst wäre dass sie das schlimmste
überstanden haben und in diesen ersten
tagen hatten sie ein ganz großes
bedürfnis nach menschlicher nähe
das hat mich am meisten beeindruckt wie
geht es mit atmen gut und die beine
die beine gut einfach die maske die ist
mühsam
ich würde sagen das wichtigste ist jetzt
wieder zu kräften zu kommen und wieder
das tun zu können was ich vorher konnte
bevor ich hierher kam war nur schon das
duschen die radfahrer sagen würden ein
anstieg auf den markt
ich brauchte etwa eine stunde und kam
völlig kaputt aus der dusche als
privatpatient berührt dich niemand
niemand ist bei dir du musst selber
klarkommen
es gibt eine große befriedigung wir
erleben unbezahlbares wir sind
privilegiert weil bei uns die akute
phase vorbei ist und wir wissen dass
diese patienten das schlimmste hinter
sich haben
das schlimmste ist vorbei und wir helfen
ihnen wieder das gefühl zu genießen wenn
sie das erste mal luft schnappen auf dem
balkon oder wie beim ersten mal wieder
radfahren
[Musik]
in der klinik novation werden seit
einigen wochen corona patienten betreut
die auch nach behandlung angewiesen sind
die physiotherapie findet im zimmer
statt
damit das risiko einer allfälligen
ansteckung anderer patienten oder des
personals vermindert wird
um die nicht profit patienten zu
schützen haben mir zwei getrennte
abteilungen eingerichtet und das
personal arbeitet entweder auf der einen
oder der anderen
wir mussten genau schauen wie wir diese
patienten pflegen und sie dabei
weiterhin peinlich genau isolieren
können
das hat natürlich unsere tägliche arbeit
beeinflusst weil wir getrennte abläufe
einrichten mussten damit auch die nicht
profit patienten die so genannten
normalen fälle in der genuss einer
angemessenen reaktionen das für sie ein
risiko besteht
[Musik]
schuldig
auch in der klinik hildebrand in
brissago ist eine eigene abteilung mit
14 betten plätzen für kobe 19 patienten
reserviert für die verschiedenen
krankheitsbilder braucht es auch
spezialisiertes personal
[Musik]
wenn ein patient in quarantäne kommt
einer der infiziert ist hat man zuerst
ängste die man kaum kontrollieren kann
aber mit der zeit merkt man ob es sich
jetzt um einen patienten mit
neurologischen problemen handelt oder um
ein mit dem virus
man muss beide genau gleich behandeln
das virus setzt nicht nur den körper zu
sondern auch der seele
auch diese verletzungen müssen behandelt
werden
wie geht s ich bin ja hier das kann ich
sagen aber wenn ich an die menschen
denken die es nicht geschafft haben das
projekt ich es sind ja nicht nur die
älteren leute die es nicht geschafft
haben sondern auch junge und dann auch
ein älterer mensch hätte wohl gern noch
länger gelebt man kann nicht einfach
sagen weil er jetzt älter ist es
zeichnet für immer und es bestimmt auch
ein wenig die art wie man in die zukunft
schaut
auch der körper braucht seinen
wiederaufbau viele patientinnen und
patienten haben vom langen liegen ihre
kraft verloren
für sie wurde eigens ein fitnessraum
eingerichtet dieser reha ist für mich
wie eine wiedergeburt
ich musste wieder gehen lernen
nach fünf wochen im bett und dem ganzen
stress für den körper
das war nicht leicht ich habe immer noch
probleme beim gehen aber das ist halt so
ich lerne schritt für schritt treppen zu
steigen
zum glück bin ich noch jung und mache
schnell fortschritte und auch die
physiotherapeuten sind zufrieden
von mir her gesehen funktioniert das
[Musik]
hallo mama ich bin froh dich zu sehen
wie schön dicht nach dieser ganzen zeit
zu sehen
[Musik]
ich habe gedacht heute versuchen wir mal
das bett zu machen
[Musik]
wie geht s einfach aber mühsam es ist
anstrengend
der ergotherapeut hilft den patienten
ihren alltag wieder selbständig zu
bestreiten
wenn sie dann nach hause zurückkehren
hilft ihnen das einerseits im alltag und
andererseits ihren körper zu trainieren
und die kraft wieder zu erlangen die sie
zum leben brauchen
der aufenthalt her innovation ist
wirklich ein wichtiger schritt wenn man
denkt was ich alles überwinden musste
man muss gegen diesen ganzen
schrecklichen misst ankämpfen
die hände hinter den nacken
zusammenbringen geht nicht aber drücken
sie nur jetzt einatmen
ich bin jetzt bald fertig mit der reha
ich kann mich praktisch allein bewegen
und seit bald einer woche kann ich mich
am morgen ganz allein duschen
versuchen sie es nochmals aber mit der
ferse nach vorn und drücken sie wir
schauen zuerst ob es an der kraft fehlt
oder ob wir uns eher um das atmen
kümmern müssen und die allgemeine
kondition unter das gleichgewicht daher
muss man mit den patienten reden sie
kennen lernen
man muss auch ein vertrauensverhältnis
aufbauen und gemeinsam schaffen wir es
die therapie ziele zu erreichen
ich schaue oft zum fenster hinaus ich
liebe den frühling und den sommer und
draußen sehe ich die zeichen dass
langsam meine jahreszeit kommt es hat
ein schwalbennest dass mir unheimlich
viel bedeutet und ich schaue auf meinen
sie ihn ab und zu vergeht der tag
[Musik]
ich wohne im dorfzentrum und muss dort
über zwei treppen steigen wenn ich hier
rauskomme
nach all den übungen was wird dann mit
den zwei treppen seien werde es
vielleicht schaffen oder nur mit einer
pause ich habe riesen große lust
heimzukehren
ich bin schon fast einen monat weg und
dann hoffe ich dass ich mit der zeit zu
hause wieder alles tun kann wie früher
[Musik]
hallo schatz hör mal ich habe gute
nachrichten
heute morgen habe ich die übliche physio
mit pascal gemacht und mein körper ist
tierisch fast wie der von luca toni
weißt du woran ich in letzter zeit denke
das bald wenn sie mich frei lassen unser
hochzeitstag kommt es werden langsam
viele klar
leider war es leider
[Musik]
hier drin leben wir wie in einer blase
ich habe angst vor dem was draußen ist
es ist ja nicht einfach eine operation
mit reha und danach ist alles wieder
normal
jetzt komme ich raus und nichts ist mehr
wie zuvor
was bleibt von virus in der lunge zurück
die schäden in der lunge scheinen gut zu
verheilen meistens vollständig da ist es
gut möglich dass die lunge wieder so
wird wie sie vor der korona infektion
war
stimmt es dass das virus auch andere
organe schädigt ja weil es die
rezeptoren an denen das virus andockt um
so in den organismus eintritt nicht nur
in der lunge sondern auch in anderen
organen und anderen gewebe gibt das
erklärt warum es zb auch er nieren
alsleber probleme gibt
das resultat des zweiten abstrichs ist
gekommen und auch dieser ist negativ
jetzt haben wir zwei abstriche mit
negativen wie schön dass wir eine tolle
nachricht
es läuft gut ihr atmungs apparat erholt
sich also das ist wirklich eine gute
nachricht
danke das ist wirklich toll ich bin
glücklich
[Musik]
ich glaube jetzt fehlt nicht mehr viel